hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
early on in metaphysics book 1 Aristotle
provides an initial account of Plato's
own metaphysical views and you know
Aristotle was in fact Plato's student so
presumably even if we can't find exactly
what he's talking about in the Platonic
dialogues there must have been some
teaching that Aristotle himself was
drawing upon and this isn't the totality
of his discussion of Plato he will
continue in the rest of the metaphysics
and at other points in other works to
talk about for example the forms and
what role they play and whether it's a
good doctrine or not but he is providing
us with a lot of discussion early on as
he's tracing out his predecessors in
terms of the four causes now Aristotle
credits Plato with only really using two
of the causes using and and that means
sort of formally recognizing and
articulating because we know from
Plato's apology and from the Phaedo and
and other texts that Plato does in fact
talk about what we could call
the final cause but he doesn't single it
out as something to study for its own
sake as Aristotle will do so Aristotle
says that Plato really only used two
causes what two causes are those one is
the essence or what we call the formal
cause by convention and here he the
location that he uses is teh two TSD tey
standing in for itea which is caused so
the cause belonging to or deriving from
what the thing is so the structure or
the in this case the form of the thing
as we're going to talk about and then he
also recognizes a material cause take
hot attained Hulan who lane is the
matter
it's the originally wood but it comes to
mean matter in general and Aristotle
identifies this with the substrate the
Hoople came and known that which
underlies something so you have form
impressed on matter and this is what we
call a high/low morphic account and he's
crediting Plato with something like this
now this discussion comes towards the
end of that short section that's
entirely focused on Plato
although bringing up the pythagorean's
by way of contrast as well and he tells
us that what Plato is doing applies on
two different levels so we have what
we're probably all familiar with from
having heard about platonism we have the
forms and the forms are the form the
formal cause for the sensible things the
many material plural things that we're
going to talk about in just a moment and
then we have the one towhead and that is
the in some way the formal cause for the
forms now it gets quite interesting here
because Aristotle
also says and he seems to be speaking
from some sort of authoritative basis
again that what Plato recognized as the
material substrate and he uses both
terms there that's why we translate it
that way who lay and Hoople came and
owned what functions as that is the
Great and the small or the large and the
small or the great and the the you know
whatever is at the very end of that and
these are conceived of in terms of
quantity you might say mega me Kron
right and these are also comparative
terms now he doesn't go on to explain
exactly how this is supposed to work but
presumably this played an important role
in Plato's teaching well we're primarily
interested in is Aristotle's own
presentation here and he tells us a
little bit about what he takes to be the
back story of how Plato arrived at these
ideas now one thing he points out that's
very important is that Plato had a
resource that the previous philosophers
including presumably Parmenides and
Heraclitus didn't have access to and
that was dialectic dialectic as a
discipline involving questioning and
answering and trying to arrive at the
truth of things through a process of
inquiry now because of that Plato was
able to take some of the ideas that were
already out there and then his training
under Socrates or Socrates influenced at
least watching Socrates engage in this
activity and bring them together into a
new synthesis that produced a new
metaphysical account Aristotle says that
Plato stuttered studied under Cratylus
and Cratylus was holding Herrick Lydian
doctrines Heraclitus was a pre-socratic
whose works we only have fragments of he
wrote a book on nature which
unfortunately we don't possess in its
entirety but one of the things that the
Herrick Lydians are definitely credited
with in Plato's dialogues and in other
places is this notion that nothing in
this material phenomenal world that we
see in front of us ever stays exactly
the same
Heraclitus is credited for having said
you can't step in the same river twice
because the river is flowing and so you
know what you have to ask the question
well what is the river then it's
something that's continually and change
and so are our bodies and so all of the
things that we encounter
now Heraclitus went on and said that
there's a low ghost that you know runs
through everything and underlies
everything and perhaps that could be the
same over time but what's important here
is that Plato is drawing the teaching
that everything that we observe with our
eyes with our tongue you know touch any
of the senses anything we encounter of
that sort all the material objects are
continually in flux they do not remain
what they are over time and they're not
entirely what they are at any given
point in time so another way of saying
this that Aristotle brings up is that
nothing material is actually knowable it
could be perceivable but it can't be
knowable in any strict sense that
constitutes a problem how can we have
knowledge of things how can we even talk
meaningfully about the things that we
encounter and this is where Socrates
brings something new to the table
Socrates focused on definitions on
trying to say what the thing itself
hosts in Greek is so Socrates would ask
don't give me examples of all sorts of
instances of courage tell me what
courage itself actually is don't give me
all sorts of instances of friendship
tell me what the core the essence of
friendship
changing definition of it actually is
and that's what they try to do in many
of the Platonic dialogues sometimes
there's some success often times without
success the success that they had was
was rather limited to saying well this
can't be a definition and this can't be
a definition so what would the
definitions actually be of them not of
the changing things but rather of and
Plato uses two different words here that
we translate in different ways the ideas
we're just actually transliterating the
Greek there
edia is is a Greek term and then the
forms the a day alright a dose is
singular for that
and Plato tends to use these fairly
interchangeably
Aristotle distinguishes them to some
degree but doesn't quite explain at this
point how they would be different from
each other so we can take them as
synonymous here for this treatment as
well so definitions are not of the
things that actually change although
they would fall into that definition
we're actually defining the ideal formal
singular non-material whatever it
happens to be for that thing to be what
it is so if we're defining courage we
are defining an immaterial form of
courage if we are defining bed then we
are defining some ideal archetype of the
bed that exists presumably someone now
Aristotle goes on and talks about the
sensible material plural things the
things that were used to encountering in
our ordinary existence as having a
relation to the form that he calls
participation ethics in right and this
comes from Matt meta a cane and and it's
a technical term that Plato is actually
in effect taking over and coining and
Aristotle says this
quite similar to what the pythagorean's
were doing and saying that everything
existed by imitation nemesis of numbers
but Plato is changing the the name to
participation meth X 'n of na of the the
forms themselves and then he says as to
what this participation or imitation
maybe they left this an open question
and then that's actually going to be a
sticking point of Aristotle's view on
platonic philosophy and metaphysics in
general but the general idea here is
that all of the plural things for
example this book this book participates
in some sort of ideal book ness or
archetype of book or pattern or there's
many different formulations that Plato
uses a form of book that is more real
and remains the same at all times in
fact it it's a eternal it's some
respects outside of time whereas within
time we have these material books that
are never quite the same and are at vast
copies of the real book out there
somewhere now one of the issues that
came up for the plate mists is well what
about numbers
Plato sometimes uses them as examples in
the dialogues that we have Aristotle
says that the plate nests following
Plato regarded numbers as something in
between the forms themselves and the
material things and he provides a sort
of tantalizing account of this which is
quite interesting he says he regarded
the numbers as distinct from sensible
things whereas they hold that things
themselves are numbers of the
pythagorean's right and he says that the
the numbers themselves or objects of
mathematics so we could think of other
things along
those lines provide an intermediary he
goes on and he says with respect to all
of these there is a material principle
which is the great and the small and and
that may connect the numbers together as
well but the essence the what it is for
it to be what makes these things what
they are the the formal cause is
actually the one now you might identify
that as many have done with what Plato
will call the form of the good or the
form of the beautiful that is not
actually discussed here and this part of
Aristotle's work it's only discussed in
terms of the one but this is a pretty
faithful depiction certainly an
interesting one of what Aristotle took
Plato his teacher to be setting forward
as a fundamental metaphysical account an
account of what is real and how
everything else is caused by it it makes
use only of two causes and Aristotle
thinks that that's going to pose a bit
of a problem
you